impose sur le revenu TVA CSG CRDS impôt
sur la fortune immobilière droit de
timbre et d'enregistrement avec ces
quelques 480 taxes impôts et cotisations
la France détient un record du monde
selon la Fondation pour la recherche sur
les administrations et les politiques
publiques mais sommes-nous pour autant
vraiment le peuple le plus taxé
avant de nous lancer dans l'examen des
chiffres tâchons d'y voir un peu plus
clair les principales recettes fiscales
perçues par l'État viennent de la TVA de
l'impôt sur le revenu et de l'impôt sur
les sociétés la TVA et l'impôt sur le
revenu concerne les particuliers l'impôt
sur les sociétés comme son nom l'indique
concerne les entreprises il en existe
beaucoup d'autres mais concentrons-nous
sur les principales ressources de l'État
notamment sur celles venant des
particuliers concrètement qui paye quoi
vont donc particulier le principal
impôts qu'on paye c'est la TVA très
simple c'est quand on achète quelque
chose on paye en pourcentage qui va dans
les caisses de l'État le l'impôt sur les
particuliers auxquels on pense aussi le
plus c'est l'impôt sur le revenu
qu'on déclare donc effectivement au
printemps on fait sa déclaration de
revenus et là-dessus on va avoir un taux
d'imposition à cela s'ajoute aussi la
taxe foncière pour les propriétaires de
biens immobiliers à laquelle peut encore
se greffer un autre impôt si on une
valeur immobilière à son nom qui est de
1,3 millions ou plus là on va payer
l'IFI qui est l'impôt qui a remplacé
l'ISF les filles c'est l'impôt sur la
fortune immobilière voilà qui est plus
clair et par rapport aux autres pays
est-ce que nous payons plus la France
est un des pays de l'OCDE ou le taux de
prélèvement obligatoire et le plus élevé
peut-être précision les prélèvements
obligatoires ce sont les impôts et les
cotisations sociales prélevées par les
administrations publiques et les
institutions européennes il existe trois
types de prélèvements obligatoires les
impôts les cotisations sociales et les
taxes fiscales reprenons en 2021 on
était deuxième juste derrière le
Danemark deuxième de l'OCDE avec un taux
de prélèvement obligatoire à 45 du PIB
en 2022 mais parmi ces prélèvements
obligatoires qu'est-ce qui coûte le plus
cher au contribuable on a un impôt sur
le revenu qui est extrêmement faible
quand on regarde ce qui rapporte et à
côté on a la CSG la CRDS les
prélèvements sociaux qui sont une
particularité de la France et qui eux
sont
naturellement relativement élevés la CSG
contribution sociale généralisée ou la
CRDS contribution de remboursement de la
dette sociale sont des taxes qui
financent entre autres le chômage les
allocations familiales les aides au
logement ou encore l'assurance maladie
ces impôts coûtent cher au contribuables
car ils servent à financer un système de
protection sociale qui est nettement
plus généreux qu'ailleurs la France un
taux un âge de départ à la retraite
relativement bas les retraités ont le
même niveau de vie que les
actifs alors que dans beaucoup de pays
ils ont des niveaux de vie plus bas de
15 à 20% de l'ensemble des actifs notre
santé est aux grandes parties publiques
il en est pareil pour l'école tout ça
fait que grosso modo la France dépense
beaucoup et donc naturellement on a
beaucoup de prélèvements obligatoires
nous payons donc beaucoup par rapport à
d'autres pays mais cet argent nous
dépensons pour l'État est-il bien
investi la qualité des services publics
pose problème effectivement
en ce qui concerne l'éducation on n'est
pas dans les meilleurs en ce qui
concerne la qualité si on peut dire les
performances de des enfants et de nos
étudiants et le second système que l'on
peut critiquer c'est le système
des hôpitaux les systèmes de la santé ou
là aussi on dépense beaucoup sans avoir
des résultats totalement satisfaisants
on n'a pas su gérer la coexistence entre
la médecine libérale et l'hôpital là
aussi il y a des progrès à faire surtout
que si les Français trouvent que leurs
impôts sont mal investis ils pourraient
remettre en cause
ce système
[Musique]